das sind die adidas gold rings 3.0 junge
können die fliegen und fast alle leute
was glaubt herzlich willkommen beim
neuen video ich hoffe ich sitz hier gut
man sieht mich gut bestimmt auf jeden
fall habe ich leute gedacht alec com
such dir mal irgendwas also eigentlich
stoppt bevor jetzt meckert öl
du musst immer nur themen die mädchen
angehen ich habe jetzt erst mal halt das
oder ich werde das jetzt erstmal für
mädchen machen weil halt keine ahnung 80
prozent meiner zuschauer weiblich sind
aber ich verspreche euch das gleiche
kommt auch noch mal für jungs also ihr
wisst doch gar nicht worum es geht
also ich hab so eine seite gefunden da
gibt es halt ziemlich viele schuhe auch
coole schuhe zum teil aber auch schuhe
da denke ich mir helfert ist das alter
ja und ich gucke jetzt einfach so nach
mädchenschulen oder schuhe für mädchen
und sagt also meine meinung dazu jetzt
meckern nicht wiederum also es ist nur
meine meinung
ich will jetzt nicht sagen die schuhe
die keine ahnung ich sage jetzt nicht
cool sind ich weiß ich also da gibt es
echt schuhe da kann man die die habe ich
noch nirgendwo gesehen von daher kann
ich da ruhig darüber meckern wenn ihr
diese schuhe hast nimmt dich nicht übel
dass ich dann sagt die studie gefallen
mir jetzt nicht so es ist doch also wir
wollen gar nicht einladen anfang direkt
man wenn ihr hier vorher noch eine
zweite folge sehen wollt wenn es euch
gefällt dass auf jeden fall nach oben da
so ich bin startklar wir fangen einfach
mal an und zwar netto sodass hier sind
die adidas basketball saison und das
sind aber mädchens steht of female also
auf jeden fall sind das frauen schuhe an
sich finde ich die echt cool so die
sehen halt so ein bisschen aus wie
diesen ich habe auch diese maxime fleiß
dabei
ich finde die kann man auf jeden fall
als mädchen tragen was ich daran so ein
bisschen an sie finde ist dieses fette
adidas da oben drüber
das ist immer so wäre das jetzt pink
alter dann würde ich sagen die gefallen
nicht allerdings kann ich so sagen ist
voll okay kann man machen also hätte ich
jetzt als mädchen die auswahl zwischen
alias und likes dieses nike sind schon
voll ausgelutscht dann würde ich jetzt
erstmal die nehmen schick alter die
knights die leto high heels in gelb ohne
witz solche schulen es ist dass man ich
habe diese schuhe noch nie wirklich noch
nie in meinem ganzen leben gesehen
schreibst du in die kommentare habt ihr
solche schuhe schon mal gesehen bzw habt
ihr die man bekommen die er
das sind so ist die futures schule so so
ich kann mir so vorstellen
die 14 sagen wir die die heutigen
slacker davon hat die mädchen die laufen
in fünf jahren mit 12 13 14 jahren
nichts ging euch jetzt wenn ihr das
gerne tag kein ding aber die laufen
nicht mehr so mit t-shirt über t shirt
über t shirts sondern solche schuhe so
geld finde ich dir jetzt irgendwie nicht
mehr also die sind schon scheiße aus
dann gibt es ja noch in blau alter was
das war leute es ist zwar nur meine
meinung aber ich würde mir diese schule
ist nicht kaufen aber wenn ihr die schön
findet dann durch die also nike stiletto
high heels in blau und gelb die namen
tue ich irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch
noch mal in die beschreibung und nein
schlägt dafür kein geld würde ich dafür
geld bekommen dann hätte ich es
gekennzeichnet aber ich krieg dafür kein
geld ich mache das einfach weil ich bock
drauf hatte und ich finde das ganz cool
so war diese schule sind eigentlich cool
normalerweise diese leuchtenden die ja
manchmal sich einfach so leute die
laufen durch die stadt und leuchten an
füßen
ich finde dass sie das kann man anziehen
aber wenn dann im club zum feiern finde
ich so und draußen auf der straße sieht
das irgendwie ein bisschen ich finde das
hier ein bisschen lächerlich aus wenn
man damit so draußen auf der straße rum
läuft weil es passt irgendwie behaupten
ich kann ihr könnt es gerne machen ist
nur meine meinung
aber diese schuhe bin ich da schon
besser als ganz normal in weiße gibt's
ja auch einfach in weiß sie sind jetzt
also fing mit also für mich hier finde
ich die guten fink mit leuchtendem pink
also das sind werte leitha pemex in pink
also light up my chemex in pink alter
was ist das bitte schön schubmann welche
das sieht aus wie adidas
das ist adidas das sind die adidas
goldings 3.0 junge können die fliegen
und hey was sind das für schuhe alter
wie hässlich wenn ihr die anschuldigung
aber ich find die motten hässlich leute
die solche schuhe nötig die göttlichen
ernst nehmen
vor sind die argumente warum stellt man
solche schuhe her ich meine da ist da
ist ein flügel dran die heißen wings
heißt der flügel
also da man wird ja immer schlimmer ohne
mich jetzt zurückhalten zu wollen das
sind die dann dass sie gerade sind die
hässlichsten schuhe die ich je in meinem
leben gesehen habe
vor allem diese flügel hinten dran nee
wartet die farben sind schon extrem
kacke so dass gold ist okay aber dann
ist blau und brot das passt doch
überhaupt nichts dran und dann auch noch
die flügel das ist der höhepunkt alter
sind die hässlich mansouri wenn ihr
sowas hab ist überhaupt nicht mein fall
also ich sag ja nur meine meinung hier
jetzt schon zum dritten mal gesagt das
sind die adidas links bei jeremy scott
oder so ein blödsinn das ist man
chilliger schule
der sieht geil aus hier steht jetzt
irgendwie gar keinen namen es sieht aus
wie so ein pinker ich hatte dir auch mal
so erfreuter ist dass ihr also sieht so
ein bisschen aus den erfolg wenn jetzt
was falsches sagen könnt ihr es mir auch
in die kommentare schreiben
allerdings finde ich den schuh cool klar
dass ping kann immer so ein bisschen ich
weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt sagen kann
aber das kann auf der einen seite immer
so ein bisschen tosti ab drüber kommen
aber auch ein bisschen aviso der show
geht voll klar dass das sieht cool aus
also den könig cool den würde ich mir
jetzt welchen mädchen möglich mit denen
glaub ich okay dann hätte ich
wahrscheinlich doch ich würd mir den
will man herzlich alexandra dann würde
ich mit diesem schuh kaufen man
vielleicht verleiht dieses video sieht
geben die mehr echt geld dafür dass wir
eigentlich cool
also wenn ihr gerade zukunft bei 10.000
euro mache ich eine zweite folge
und dann sah ich meine wegen auch dass
dieser schuh kulisse also überlegt euch
10.000 euro ja also diesen air force in
pink oder wie auch immer das für ein
modell ist könnte ich mir auf jeden fall
lohnen und dieser studie habe ich jetzt
gefunden das ist ein airmax it service
net micro transgen red white silver ich
auf jeden fall geile schuhe ich habe mir
jetzt für jungs und ähnlichen gut er ist
allerdings komplett so in diesem musste
also an sich der schuh kann man auf
jeden fall mal anziehen
wir sind auf jeden fall echt coole
schuhe dabei zwar auch welche diesen
posten hässlich allerdings ist was ja
cool also wenn ihr eine zweite folge
sehen wollte last auf jeden fall noch
nach oben da ich fand es irgendwie ganz
witzig macht auf jeden fall borgmann
über schuhe zu reden weil ich schaue
auch selber ganz gut finde und ich auch
nicht wenige parcours ab okay geht einem
so viele paar schuhe ob ich jetzt auch
mit ansonsten würde ich sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann hat sich
wahrscheinlich gefallen ich hab ja
gesagt also zweite folgen
verlassen daumen nach oben da kommentar
könnt ihr auch gerne schreiben hier
könnt ihr auch gerne mal eure schule
schicken die cool findet die ich mal so
ein bisschen bewerten soll einfach bei
instagram facebook was weiß ich schick
mir das einfach dazu und bild oder so
ansonsten aber nicht weil jetzt ein
zweites standbein bildet hier oben links
geht noch weiter mit meinem letzten
video zeigt dass auf jeden fall ist cool
waren glaube ich auch stimmt und wir
sehen uns dann am nächsten donnerstag
abend wahrscheinlich wieder
ich weiß noch nicht genau videos kommen
immer in der woche jetzt wenn ich bock
haben zwei drei leute denn es komme ich
da vorne gar nicht dran